so Iceland literally went bankrupt
Iceland is a country of 320,000 people
so a very small country and they the
International Monetary Fund and the
European Union wanted to take control of
Iceland's debt and the people of Iceland
basically were like wait a minute we
didn't do this this was all the bankers
that were doing this is very small
amount of people that were doing this
and they decided that they were gonna
fire all the bankers and put them in
jail and that they were gonna take
control of their debt so there were
riots there were protests and eventually
the government resigned okay are you
with me so far like we got all out here
so then the government resigns they vote
in a new government and the new
government says we are going to have you
all pay a hundred euros a month for 15
years at 5% interests and that's going
to pay off the deck but the people still
weren't happy about that because they
didn't incur the debt this was again
this was bankers and all this financial
trickery they didn't want to do that so
why am i bringing this all up because I
think this is a great great story
eventually they kicked out the
government and they figured out a way to
make the debt basically go away and not
have the world come in and control the
Icelandic economy so the head of state
refused to ratify the law that would
have made Iceland citizens responsible
for its bankers debts and accepted calls
for a referendum Interpol put out an
international arrest warrant for the
ex-president of couting that's the
biggest bank there and the other bankers
implicated in the crash fled the country
they decided to draft a new constitution
that would free the country from the
exaggerated power of international
financial and virtual money we got a
little bit more here and then they
decided to write a new constitution the
people of Iceland and elected 25
citizens from among 522 adults not
belonging to any political party but
recommended by at least 30 citizens the
document was written on the internet and
constituents meetings are streamed
online and citizens can send their
comments and suggestions witnessing the
document as it takes shape ok giving you
a lot of stuff there but the reason I
thought this was important is because we
have such a problem with money in
politics here and these people they
actually said no to the banks they said
no to the bailouts they
fired and put people in jail who did
everything wrong it is completely the
reverse of everything we've done in this
country we bailed these people out
nobody got fired and these and they got
rid of the debt debt that they did not
incur the regular people like the three
of us did not they are not incurred and
saddled with the debt I think this is a
great story and it's completely
underreported and now I've talked a lot
so please I am so thrilled that you're
actually covering this story because
this is an actual story of returning
power to people what people in this
country actually talk about and the
thing that we don't do the other thing
that's really amazing this is like the
modern version of the Continental
Congress they're coming in there they're
drafting new legislation a new
constitution but then beyond that
they're getting input from the web from
people who are watching it virtually
this is absolutely incredible it's like
it's like electing a delegate and then
being there as they represent you it's
an awesome thing to watch it happens
yeah and everything about this is the
reverse of how we do things here so not
only firing the bankers and putting
people in jail which we don't do but
having it be an open process remember
even when Obamacare was getting passed
they said oh well everyone will be
welcome and we'll put it on c-span but
never happened it was all behind closed
doors is there any chance we can look at
something like this and go I wish maybe
in maybe in Sherman Oaks California well
just I'm saying cuz we have way too many
people and with the amount of people
that we have and the history that we
have as a country yeah
they have 300,000 people more people
watch the Superbowl than they have in
their entire country yeah more and more
people watch an average football game so
of course they can kind of come to some
sort of agreement and all the people and
I hate to say this but the backgrounds
of the people are pretty much the same
you know that's Norse yeah background
right so they can all kind of agree on
what will my grandfather and my
grandfather they all thought the same
thing in this country we have it's a
melting pot of people who just got here
yesterday yeah you know from Iceland
you know people that just immigrated
here they're not going from that's true
but you know we just don't have that the
same
consistency and continuity unfortunately
in this country so is that one of the
major catch-22 of America because the
melting pot is amazing it's what has
made America what it is but then when it
comes to something like this because we
all know we can't agree on because our
shared experience is so different I'll
tell you I don't I don't necessarily
think it's the melting pot issue that
would cause a problem here I think it's
more our election process that would
cause a problem there's so much money
and we're seeing election laws you
overturned and people companies now have
freedom of speech and can put millions
and millions and millions of dollars
into specific political candidates who
then Oh a favor
the reason this thing won't happen here
is because of the way we elect our
officials and how we allow big money to
get into the process that's going to be
the real issue because I think once you
get into this country and you see how
things work I don't even know that it's
a difference in background that changes
the way that you think about it I think
people start seeing what might be better
we just can't get officials in who will
actually do it because our election
process is so messed up
yeah so that actually is a great set
when I say melting pot I do mean racism
I'm sorry should be more clear no play
we have a history in this country where
there's still a lot of anger and a lot
of inequality and they just don't have
that so it's much smaller it's a smaller
scale it's a smaller country they don't
have slavery you know they don't have
this history of like you know black
people couldn't vote until just you
don't need a few decades ago so that's
why I but it's big couples what you're
saying it's couples with the election
process because we're so polarized
political we have the Democrats and then
the right wing and then these liberals
and then no one's really in the middle
and they say they are but they're not
and so it muddies up everything and we
can't it's like we freakin we can't get
along I know that's such a terrible
bumper sticker to take it back to bumper
stickers but why can't we all just get
along they obviously figured it out in
Iceland yeah well doesn't this also go
to show how the media is also embedded
with big money and big policy under this
because nobody knows about this story
know about it yeah but I someone tweeted
about there's a Twitter yeah well there
you go but you know a lot of people this
is not the type of thing that's being
shown on CNN let's put it that way so
that media is not giving us a chance to
realize even that things can change cuz
they would never show this hell you
think Fox is going to show it
about about the big banks not winning in
the end like we just have this theory
here that we're just sort of never gonna
win and the sad thing is is that these
big media companies now aren't just
we're not just talking about media here
in the United States you know you've got
a company like Fox they're huge in
Australia they're huge in Europe so it's
it's we're dictating the conversation
that's happening globally not just
aren't they like 20 percent owned by a
Saudi king by the way nobody else nobody
talks about that but why it's not talked
about yeah yeah his wife can't drive
yeah she probably she might be on the
compound right in a golden yeah so can
we twist this anyway that's we're gonna
feel good about this end of the segment
that things can change possible they can
but you know it's hard to put Iceland on
the spotlight when you know all we know
about Iceland is Bjork and a swan dress
some saying like no one in this country
even knows what Iceland is yeah and so
that's the first challenge is getting
people to actually look outside of their
little you know their their little
neighborhood their little cul-de-sac the
crazy thing is is that Iceland kind of
represented what was going on globally
and people who were really in the know
actually looked to Iceland even when the
economic crisis was happening so if they
can look to Iceland to see what was
going wrong I mean they were basically
exactly like a smaller version of Wall
Street just making really bad financial
decisions and their economy grew nine
times between 2003 and 2007 and people
were looking - that is like what's gonna
happen here so maybe they'll do the same
thing politically they can look to that
country of what could potentially happen
versus what happened here and then maybe
if people start hearing about it then
you've got an uprising and thanks to you
people are gonna hear about it
you
[Music]